Okay. So, good morning. Today we
finished the French Revolution trilogy.
Um, so we are focusing on Napoleon today
and my argument to you today is that
Napoleon would not have been possible
without ropes PR. Okay. So, um to
illustrate this point, let us do a
thought experiment. I am going to
present to you two
individuals. Okay.
And I want you to think about who is the
greater genius, who is the uh more rare
leader. Okay? So let's look at person A.
Person A has a perfect
memory. That's the
first characteristic. He is able to
have instant recall. He or she is able
to absorb all the information that comes
his or her away and is able to retain
it. Okay. Second thing is the ability to
have priorities. So what's rare among um
really smart people is the capacity to
prioritize what is important information
and what is not important information to
filter things out. Okay? Because once
you have the important information, you
are much uh more capable capable of
making the correct decisions. Right? The
third thing is the strategic
imagination.
So a general is able to take all the
relevant information that he or she has
obtained and then imagine the
battlefield across multiple
nations. He or she is able to imagine
how the battle will
progress. And the fourth is the idea of
flexibility. So even though the general
has a plan, he or she is still flexible
during the battle. So if the battle is
not going going according to plan then
he or she he or she will make
adjustments to the battlefield because
he or she has total battlefield
awareness. Okay. So these are the four
characteristics of a great
leader. Now let's look at B. And B only
does one thing. B
is I
promote the
talented. That's all B does. That's all
B cares
about. Uh so who among these two
individuals do you think is the more
rare individual, the greater leader, the
stronger
genius? A or B?
Okay, so obviously it's a trick
question. Okay, it's obviously B, right?
And so what I'm going to do today is
explain why it's B. Because A is
Napoleon. Napoleon, like Alexander the
Great, like Julius Caesar is a genius of
war. He's able to completely imagine the
battlefield and come up with strategies
that are shocking, innovative, and
unique. That's Napoleon.
B is rogues PR. All rogues PR cares
about is promoting and rewarding those
who are true and loyal to the
revolution. Okay. So I'm making I today
I will make the argument that Rose Pier
is the greater man than Napoleon. So um
to illustrate this point, I want to ask
you a question. Okay, let's just say
that I'm a very rich man. Maybe I'm Jack
Ma and I have a huge company. I employ
thousands of workers. Um, I'm extremely
profitable. I have a son. He's 18 years
old and he's expecting to inherit my
company at 40, 50. Okay. But I say to my
son, I have a I sit I sit him down. I
have a very long dinner conversation
with him. I explain to him um son, it
takes a particular type of person to run
a great company. It takes dedication. It
takes virtue. It takes selflessness.
You're a great person. I love you
because you're my son, but you're not
qualified to run my company. I have a
team of experts who will replace me
after I'm dead. I'm sorry, son, but you
have to go do something else. Okay?
Because quite honestly, I don't think
you would even enjoy running my
company. Okay? So, that's a thought
experiment. Right? Now, let me ask you
this question. China has 1 billion
people. Would there be anyone in China
who would think I'm a good
father? No one. Okay, that's why B is
hard because B requires a
selflessness. But not only that, but B
requires the capacity to ignore social
values and focus on what is good by
itself.
Okay, that's why B is harder than A. And
and quite frankly, A in history, we'll
meet a lot of individuals like that.
Julius Caesar, Napoleon, Hitler, uh even
today, um there are quite a few
individuals like A. But B is rare. All
right. So, let me explain why B is so
rare and why Rose Pier was fundamental
to the birth of Napoleon. All right. So,
we're going to focus on a battle and
this is 1805.
Ashelins. This is considered Napoleon's
greatest battle. Okay. The war the
battle that made Napoleon into a legend.
This is something called the war of the
third coalition. So Napoleon, the French
are up against three major nations,
right? The Austrians, the Russians, and
the British. The Prussians will come out
come in at some point to join the third
coalition. So Napoleon needs to act
first and knock out both Russia and
Austria before the Prussians come in
because Prussia is considered at this
point the greatest military in the
world. All right. So this is Oshelitz
the battlefield. Let me first give you
um an overview of what the battlefield
looks like. First of all, you have the
coalition
forces stationed on high ground. Okay,
these are about 70,000
troops. Napoleon is scattered. Okay,
he's got his forces here and he's got
his forces here on the right. This this
is a right and these are his main
forces. Okay, this is Napoleon and these
he also has about 70,000 troops. So they
look even but actually the coalition
forces have a huge advantage. One
because they're on high ground. Okay.
Second is that they are coming more
forces are coming in from behind to to
bolster the forces. All right. So it
looks in the beginning like the
coalition forces will overwhelm
Napoleon.
Okay. But and so what the uh the um
coalition forces are going to do is
this. They see the right flank of
Napoleon. It's weak. So what they will
do is they will send a right attack and
overwhelm the right and then come behind
Napoleon. and then the other forces will
come down to envelop um Napoleon. This
this this is what we call a flanking um
attack. Okay. So that is the plan and
quite honestly this is the most logical
the most reasonable strategy given the
circumstances. What they don't know is
this Napoleon anticipates that they will
do this. It's a trap actually. Okay.
Because what's going to happen is that
as they come and attack, Napoleon will
now attack the coalition's right flank.
And as the coalition tries to muster the
right flank,
the cavalry will come in and split the
coalition into two, forcing them to
retreat. Okay, that is the master plan.
The problem with this plan is the right
flank. The right flank needs to hold
against the coalition attack. Otherwise,
the coalition will just sweep in and um
outflank Napoleon. Napoleon has this
plan where coming
in to um bolster the right flank is his
marshall Davo with 10,000 men. Okay. The
problem though is that Davo is 100
kilometers away. So, it has to be a
really quick march to the right flank.
Okay. Now, if he misses, the coalition
will just wipe out this
army.
But he does get here in time. He saves
the right flank and then the rest of the
plan goes exactly according to
Napoleon's vision, his strategy. It is
perfect. Okay, perfect timing,
uh, perfect attack. Everything is
perfect. And as a result, this is
exactly what happens. Napoleon splits
the coalition into two. They're forced
to retreat. And then what will happen is
that Napoleon will sweep in and capture
this entire army. Okay? Once this
happens, the war is over. The Russians
and the Austrians are forced to retreat.
The Austrians sue for peace. The
Russians go home. Okay? So this is
considered one of the greatest battles
in human history. It is up there with
the great battles. This is considered
the defining achievement of Napoleon.
And there are certain characteristics
about this battle that make it uniquely
Napoleon. Okay. The first is is total
battlefield
awareness. That's the first thing. He is
able to imagine entire battlefield even
before this battle starts. He knows
exactly where each unit will be. Okay.
So total battlefield awareness is what
makes Napoleon unique. What also makes
Napoleon unique at this time is the idea
of
speed. This all happens very very fast.
Um at this time in Europe, battles are
fought slowly and it's really like two
forces banging against each other. Okay.
But this is really fast and what you
have is a lot of maneuverability.
Okay. Okay. Usually in the battlefield
the army fights as one unit. What's
amazing about Napoleon is he's able to
divide his forces into different smaller
armies that operate independently but as
part of a larger vision. Okay. So
Arcelitz is the defining achievement of
Napoleon's grand strategy of war. And if
you go to military college if you want
to be a general you will have to study
this war this battle in great
detail. All right. So the problem with
this plan is that um it should not have
worked. Okay, it is a reckless and
stupid way to fight a battle because
there are about 10,000 ring ways that
that that could go wrong. Okay, first of
all, you need this guy DVO to come in.
He has to do about 110 kilometers in 48
hours. This is this was this was before
considered impossible. A really strong
army, really disciplined, really well
trained will do at most 20 kilometers in
one day. Okay, think about that. This is
the best army in the world. The
Prussians will do 20 km in one day. The
VO is able to do 110 kilometers in two
days. All right? And that just shows you
how extremely disciplined the French
are. Not only are they able to do 110
kilometers in 48 hours, but they come
into the battlefield fresh for battle.
Okay, they jump straight on the battle
and they are pushing the coalition
forces back. So, it's an incredible
achievement by Dvau. In fact, if you
study um military history, you will see
a lot of people argue that Dvau was the
far superior general to Napoleon. Okay?
because it takes a lot of skill to
marshall your forces and organize them
in a way that they will want to march
that fast in that quick amount of time.
Okay, so the first thing that must have
happened is the VO had to come in time.
But you know what? There could have been
rain, right? He could have gotten lost.
An army could have come in and blocked
his his advance, right? So 10,000 things
could have gone wrong. Napoleon was
really lucky that these things didn't go
wrong. Also in this in um this attack by
the French, it was
possible that the coalition could have
overwhelmed an attack.
Okay. So in other words, the thing about
Napoleon that's really important is yes,
his strategic genius is one thing, but
what really matters is the officers
under him. Okay. He had a really
talented bench of officers who were
committed to the battle and they knew
exactly what they had to do. Napoleon
was the one with the vision. He was the
one who had the courage and the bonus to
attack. But it was they who executed the
plan
perfectly. All right? And that's the
defining characteristic of the grand
army of
Napoleon. All right?
So let me explain to you how this
happened. Okay. How was it that the
French was able to build Europe's
greatest army during the French
Revolution. All right. So let's compare
the Prussians and the
French. And the Prussians again are
considered at this time in European
history the greatest army ever. Right?
So they are run by the nobility. The
officers, the generals are nobility and
they are called the yunkers. This is
very important. I want you guys to
remember the the the term yners. Okay,
they are the elite of part society.
They're the ones who will take Germany
into World War I and World War II. Okay,
they are the force behind Hitler and
they are considered um the greatest
warriors in European history at this
time, the
Yunkers. They are landed nobility. They
have their land and so they can focus
completely on warfare. And as time
progresses, they become the greatest
generals and officers of Europe at this
time. Let's look at the soldiers. The
soldiers come from three sources. The
first is conscription. Okay,
conscription just means that you draft
people
um from your nation to join the war.
Second is volunteers. Why do people
volunteer? Because you're often treated
better in the military than you are um
in a nation. If you are a soldier, the
nobility can't beat the crap out of you
for no reason. But if you're a peasant,
the nobility can beat the crap out of
you for no particular reason. Okay? And
the third, which is the most
controversial, are deserters. So the
Prussians have a nasty reputation for
arresting people who they believe ran
away from other armies like the French
and British army and they are forced
into the Persian army. It's like
basically prison. Now the they have a
nasty reputation because a lot of these
desertters actually not deserters. They
just happen to be people from
neighboring nations that the Persians
kidnap into their army. Okay. So you
have these three main sources. Now the
thing that makes the Persian army unique
in Europe is it actually has very strict
requirements for joining the military.
You have to be tall. Basically you have
to be like 5'8. The average height was
like 5'6 at this time in Europe.
Napoleon himself was 5'7. You have to be
5'8. Okay, so Napoleon would not have
been able to join the Persian army. You
have to be 5'8. It's the tallest army in
the world. The Persian king Feder the
Great has has takes tremendous pride in
how tall his warriors are. Okay. All
right. So um this extremely disciplined
army. But with this army comes three
fundamental weaknesses. Okay. The first
is they cannot
afford to lose that many men. Okay,
these are these men are extremely well
trained. They're extremely well
disciplined. They cannot afford to lose
that many soldiers in battle. Okay,
that's the first problem. Second problem
is they're extremely slow. Why are they
slow? Because um the officers like to
live well. Okay. So, so wherever they
go, there's maybe like three or four
different tra wagons that carry their
food, carry their clothing, carry their
servants. Okay. So, this is a very slow
army, but it's fine because every other
army in Europe is slow as well. Okay.
Um, and so this creates an problem of
inflexibility. The Persians fight one
way and that's the only way they fight.
They basically move up front and because
of the discipline of their soldiers,
they overwhelm their enemy. They don't
have that much flexibility in their
army. Okay, so these are the three
fundamental weaknesses of a Prussian
army. They cannot afford casualties.
They're extremely slow and their
strategy is inflexible, right? But it's
not a problem because every army in
Europe suffers from the same problems
now comes the French Revolution. Okay.
The French Revolution robes Pierre takes
charge of organization and personnel
hiring basically for the new French
revolution army and he makes radical
changes to the French military. The
first is the idea of a
meritocracy. Okay. So before like every
army most of the French army the
officers and generals were of nobility
that were appointed by the king. They
were loyal to the king and as such roar
saw them as a threat. Right? So he
basically replaced the nobility with
young men from the provinces who
believed in a revolution. So at the
beginning of the revolution about 85% of
all officers French were
nobility. Five years later it's about
3%. That's a huge huge change. Okay. One
of one of these men that that's
recruited into the French military and
promote very really fast is Napoleon.
Napoleon by the age of 25 is a general
and that's unheard of at Europe at this
time. But it's not just Napoleon. It's
like dozens and dozens of really
talented young men um who are given
opportunities they would not have been
given anywhere else. Also what's
important for us to remember is that
Napoleon himself is not French. He's
Corsican. Okay, he's a foreigner. But
because of French Revolution, he's given
these tremendous opportunities. Right?
So that's that's the first thing. It's a
meritocracy. Second thing is it is total
war. In other words, it is complete
conscription. There are no volunteers.
There are no desertters. It's everyone
must now join the army. Okay. So now
France has almost this end
supply of soldiers. And that gives the
French three major advantages. The first
is high casualties. They can actually
afford now to lose a lot of men in
battle. So the French are now willing to
take risks that other armies are not
able to take. For example, ostelates,
right? Oculus was a huge huge gamble
that paid out for the French, but
they're able to do so because able to
replenish the forces if need be. Okay,
high casualties. Second is the idea of
mobility, speed. All right, so now you
don't have any you don't have any
officers. Well, you can travel really
fast. Also, your soldiers can just live
off the land. You don't have to feed
them like great food. They can just go
and find berries or chickens to cook for
themselves. Okay? So, they are able to
travel at least three times as fast as
their enemies. That's an incredible
advantage because even before their
enemies are able to set up camp, the
French have surrounded them and
overwhelmed them. Okay, this happens a
lot during these wars. So, speed is the
crucial factor. And the third advantage
is
flexibility. If you have an extremely
dedicated army, what you're able to do
is you're able to divide them into
different units called corpse. Okay? Um
this is no different from the Roman
legion. Uh the Roman legion was the uh
main tactic of the Roman army back in
the old days. Okay? So what you do is
you take a huge army, you divide them
into smaller armies, and if they're able
to travel really fast, what this army is
able to do is really quickly surround
the enemy. Okay? If you surround the
enemy, the enemy is dead. The the the
biggest problem in war is being
encircled because you've cut off their
supply roots. Um they don't know how how
to respond to encirclement. Okay? So the
French for many years was just
destroying the enemies because of these
three factors. They're able to take high
casualties, their speed and their
strategic flexibility in battle. Okay.
And who created the system? Ropes Pier
created the system. Ropes Pier, not
Napoleon. Ropes
Pier. All right. So, um, to give you an
illustration of what the difference is,
let's go to the year
1806. Okay. So, the French have
destroyed the Austrians. The Russians
are in retreat. The Prussians come to
battle now. Okay. and and all of Europe
is like, "Oh, wow. The Prussians now
have taken the battlefield. The
Prussians are going to overwhelm the
French because the French are just
peasant recruits. The Prussians are
tall. They're strong. They're fearless.
They're going to destroy the French."
Okay. So, the for the first time since
the revolution, the Prussians and the
French meet in
1806. Okay. Um it is a total and utter
annalation. Okay. Never before has
Europe seen this. the French in 30 days
wipes out the entire Persian army. It is
incredible to watch. Also, there's a
very famous battle during this time
where Dvau
um he's a court leader and he gets lost
and he ends up fighting the entire
Prussian
army. Okay, you you know about this
battle, right? Um and he's out number
two to one. He wins the battle.
DVO is able to win uh out number two to
one against the main Prussian army led
by the king himself. Okay. So this is a
radical revolution in military affairs.
The French by using the system is able
to dominate Europe for
uh most of Napoleon's reign. Okay. But
but and what this does is and this is
really important is this because the
French are dominating the battlefield it
forces the other European powers to make
fundamental changes to society because
the French of the French revolution
these sides are forced to become more
liberal and democratic and open and
progressive in order to defeat Napoleon.
So after 1806 the pressure to make a lot
of major changes to society. Okay. What
they recognize is that our soldiers
aren't enough. We need to change the
fabric and structure of our society if
we are to defeat Napoleon. Okay. So
um they make two major changes there.
There's other changes but there are two
major changes that that is fundamental.
The first is they abolish surfom. Okay.
Surfdom. Surfdom is basically like
slavery where the peasants are tied to
the land and that's the majority of
people. When you abolish surfom the
advantage of that is now you can have
more conscription. these prices are now
able to come and become soldiers because
serves are not allowed to be soldiers.
Okay? So now your army the numbers have
increased and so all the armies at this
time Europe are increasing because
they're allowing more people to join the
military. Okay. And the second which is
most important is the middle class. So
uh before the French revolution all
Europe was extremely structured
stratified society. They're really at
the top but because of Napoleon's
victories the Prussians allow the middle
class to join the civil service. That's
fundamental. Okay. They are now
activating the energy of the middle
class and this allows for innovation. It
allows for um more e economic activity.
And so 1806 even though the presence are
destroyed, it allows them to build a
structures that will allow them to
dominate all of Europe in about you know
50 60 years time and eventually they'll
become the dominant power in Europe and
the world basically uh before the
beginning of World War I. And this was
all possible because the Prussians lost
to the French and they learned lessons
from the French Revolution. Okay, that's
why I keep on saying the French
Revolution was a turning point in uh
human civilization. Okay, so that is my
main argument. Um are any questions
about this argument
confused
about the can join the army. Okay. So,
surfom. Okay. All right. So, the idea
the institution of surfom it's basically
slavery where peasants are tied to the
land. They cannot leave the land. And
this is important because again most of
these societies are agricultural based.
So you need people actually to work the
land. And as such your the majority of
your population is not eligible for the
military. Okay, that does that make
sense? when you eliminate surfom now
every man is eligible for the military
and as such you can um replenish your
forces and a lot of men want to join the
military because it's a lot better to be
a soldier than to be a peasant right as
a soldier you h you you are um given
rights by the military okay because the
military is a very powerful institution
if you're a soldier you can't be bullied
around by anyone whereas where whereas
if you're a peasant you're a surfer you
you I you you're like an animal. Okay?
So if if you give people a choice
whether to join the military or be a
surf, they would choose to be a soldier
even though there's a risk of death.
Okay? But with a soldier comes a
possibility of social mobility and
social respect which is not available to
you if you are a surf. Okay, does that
make sense? Great.
I had a question. Um the so like earlier
on in the in the French Revolution there
there were wars against Prussia that the
the French also won and one of the
reasons for that that often come up is
that they had like it was ideological
reasons that the the French at that time
were the spirit of the French that's
right the ideology of
it nationalism all that kind of stuff
right um you move up 15 years into the
Napoleonic period. Are those ideals of
the French Revolution still part of the
army or was it more of like a a speed of
co like we're just a bunch of young men
moving up in the world and this is our
new identity as imperial? Yeah. Okay,
that's a great question. Okay, so the
beginning of the revolution these
revolutionaries were compelled by re a
sort of a religious fever to die for the
nation. Okay. And Rose Pierre became the
role model because Rosier sacrificed
himself uh for uh for for France. Um but
in 1804 what happens is Napoleon becomes
emperor. And once he becomes emperor,
everything changes because now you're
not you're no longer fighting for your
nation, you're fighting for your
emperor. And there are a lot of French
people who felt betrayed by Napoleon. So
after 1804, this is really important.
France is still the greatest military in
the world, but it's basically a military
cabapow, a military cabal, okay, who run
France. Uh Napoleon is just the head of
a group of generals who love war, who
benefit from war. Um and um as such,
France becomes a military nation where
everyone's supporting the French um um
military adventurism. Okay? And even
though the French do win a lot of wars,
eventually because you're an empire, you
just exhaust everyone. Okay. But but but
I will discuss this during the PPT.
Okay. All right. So, thank thank you.
All right. Any more questions before I
go into the uh
PPT? Okay. All right. So, one last point
is why is Rose Pierre creating a
meritocracy? Okay. The reason why he's
creating a meritocracy is remember he's
trying to create a new society and there
are a lot of threats to this new
society. Obviously the major threat is
these foreign armies like the Prussians,
the Austrians, uh the Spanish who want
to restore the Burban monarchy. That's a
major threat. Then you have these rebels
uh these peasants who want to restore
the the privileges of the Catholic
Church. That's also another major
threat. But the main threat is actually
the army itself, right? Because remember
85% of the army is nobility. And there
were actually a few c few times when the
army wanted to march against the
revolution and restore the monarchy and
the generals didn't do that even though
they wanted to because they were afraid
that the soldiers would mutiny against
them. Okay. Okay. So this was a huge
problem for Robespier and that's why
Robespier um spearheaded the movement to
replace no nobles with ordinary men like
Napoleon which gave Napoleon opportunity
to rise among uh to rise within the
ranks. Okay. Does that make sense?
That's the logic of the revolution. All
right. All right. So um let us now go
into the details of this now that we've
done an
overview. Right.
So
sorry. All
right. So the question we were looking
at today is how did a nobody Okay. And
this guy l literally was a nobody. He
was from a from an island called Corsica
which was not even French. He was part
of the French Empire but it's not
actually French. Um he grew up speaking
French but in a very bad accent. Okay.
So people made fun of him in school. His
family was local nobility in Corsica but
they were poor. Okay. So this guy was
literally a nobody and in only like I
don't know like a decade he became
emperor of France the French empire
which at that time was the um main power
in Europe. So how is this possible? How
did the nobody Napoleon become emperor
of French? Okay. So for us to understand
this remember what the French revolution
was. These three classes we look at very
closely at the French Revolution and my
argument to you is it was a religious
crusade. Okay, this the the the irony of
course is the French Revolution was
trying to re remove religion from social
life. Okay, but if you look at what
actually happened to the French
Revolution, it was the ultimate
religious crusade where the people were
willing to sacrifice their lives in
order to build a new society based
entirely on reason. Their new god was
reason.
Okay. Um, another idea I want you to
remember is that mythologies are
prophecies and prophecies are plans of
action. Okay. So, embedded in your
subconscious are the mythologies of
society. Um, in France at this time
these mythologies included the stories
of Jesus but also the stories of Exom
the Great and Julius Caesar. Napoleon
saw himself as the
reincarnation of both Exod the Great and
Julius Caesar and he wanted to create a
mythology that he was in fact the
Messiah. Okay, so these mythologies are
there and Napoleon saw this as an
opportunity in order for him to amass
power for himself. That was his main
insight. Okay, he was not a great
general. That is one of the major mis
misconceptions out there. He was not a
great general who was not as good as
Davo was. But he understood that the
underlying framework for society are
mythologies. If you can control these
mythologies, you can control people. You
can become the emperor. Okay? That was
his major uh
revelation. All right. So three things
to remember. Mythologies are part of the
collective subconscious. Okay. We are
all in society um governed by the
mythology that we share together. That's
the first idea. Second idea is that when
collective subcon sorry when collective
consciousness authority breaks down
these mythologies begin to drive
history. So when you remove your
teachers it doesn't mean no one's in
charge. It just means that now these
mythologies are in charge. Okay. So
think of the cultural revolution in
China. You could remove these authority
figures but then your subconscious takes
charge. And the third idea is certain
individuals will act out the leading
roles in these mythologies and capture
the imagination attention of everyone
else. Okay, that's why Napoleon became
emperor because he saw that the French
were looking for a
messiah. And he and he's like I will
become your messiah. And he did that by
acting it out by pretending to be ex the
great but pretending to be Julius
Caesar. Okay? And I I'll show you how
later on. Okay? So that's a main idea
we're looking at today. All right? And
Napoleon himself said this. Okay, this
is a very famous quote that he said uh
while he was in exile in St. Helena.
Okay, so he's basically writing his
memoirs. He's reflecting on his life and
he's not that perceptive. He's not that
bright. But in this quote, we see his
plan his like like how he became
emperor. Okay, let's let's read this. I
saw the way to achieve all my dreams. I
would found a religion, right? He's not
like I'm not a general. I am a religious
leader. I saw myself marching into Asia
mounted on an elephant a turban on my
head that is actually the great that's
as Caesar okay and in my hand a new
Quran that I would have composed to suit
my needs a Quran a Bible okay so that's
what he saw so he understood what the
French revolution really was it was a
crusade to bring reason into the world
and he would become the Muhammad the
Julius Caesar that's the great the Jesus
that would
achieve this crusade
Okay, does that make sense? He
understood this from the beginning and
that's why he was able to succeed.
Whereas Rose Pier um he may have
understood this but he refused to act
out that role.
Right? All right. So even even in his
beginning the beginning of his career he
was focused on creating mythology of
himself. This is this is when he was
first a general and was part of the
Italian campaign. And this is a
mythology of him leading his warriors
into battle. Okay, this didn't really
happen this way. Doesn't matter because
he understood that what matters is how
people perceive you. The reality the
underlying reality doesn't really
matter. So when he was emperor, he was
focus focusing on a cult of personality.
Okay, paintings of himself, stories of
himself that would um become the
official history. So a lot of stuff that
we know about Napoleon his victories we
have to be suspicious about. Okay.
Because he was so focused on creating a
myth of himself.
Okay. All right. So um let's go over
some details that we discussed. All
right. So um when Lu 16 was in charge
the French army had a lot of problems.
The first problem was you had too many
generals. 5 5678 generals, 480,000 men.
That's a lot of generals. Okay? And the
reason why they had these generals is
they were friends of the king. They
weren't competent. They weren't
necessary, but the king liked them and
so the king promoted them, right? It was
a way to ensure the nobility was loyal
to you. But that made for a topheavy
um bureaucracy that didn't allow for
innovation and change. Okay, so that's
the first problem. Second problem is 85%
are nobles, harsh discipline. Um
soldiers didn't want to fight, they were
forced to fight. No conscription,
volunteer army, basically deserters.
One-third would desert every year. Okay?
One-third of soldiers run would run away
every year. So this so that's why this
army is problematic. Okay? And that's
why the Prussians, the English would
defeat the French in many battles before
the
revolution. All right? So this man is
named uh Carno and he is actually a
friend of Rose Piers. They were they
became friends when Ropes Pier um was in
his provincial town of Ays. They they've
known each other for like a long long
time. And when Rose Pier became
prominent in the revolution he asked his
friend Carnau to come up with a new
system of reorganizing the military. And
Carno came he's a ma mathematician, a
scientist. He came up with the idea of
conscription. Let's call it le and math.
So let's get everyone to join the
military so as to dilute the influence
of nobility. And it works spectacularly
well. And because he he's a
mathematician, he was extremely well
organized. Okay. He is one of the main
conspirators against ropes pier um
because he when he amassed power he
recognized that he couldn't really
benefit from his power. Rose Pierre was
too virtuous. He demanded on everyone
making sacrifices. And so these people
that Rose Pierre promoted that um Rose
Pierre favored would eventually conspire
against him. Okay. And one of these men
is Carno. And Carno is is also important
because Carnau would make Napoleon a
general. Okay. So the thing about
Napoleon that makes him distinctive in
the military is he's very good at
um um coming close with political
patrons. Okay? He's very good at
identifying political patrons and
getting them to help him in his
career. All right. So as you can see
because of conscription the French army
is increasing and that forces the other
armies of Europe to increase as well.
Okay. So you can see the spike
um during this time because all of all
these reforms military many young great
generals are emerging in the French
military. So Napoleon is the most famous
but there are others who are actually
just as good even better than Napoleon.
Okay, dozens of them and they these
generals will become the core of the
French military. All
right. And all of them are driven by a
republican idealism. Okay? They want
French become a republic. They want
French to be France to be free. They
want to spread the revolution all across
the world. Not not not only are they um
devoted and idealistic, but also their
soldiers. The soldiers are willing to
die in battle, whereas the others are
whereas other nations are not. Okay. Um
the VO we talked about. Okay. Without
the VO, there's no way Napoleon could
have won his battles. The VO is probably
the greatest general at this time.
Um,
so Carno makes Napoleon a general. And
why is Napoleon given the general ship?
Because Napoleon does the
um Carno a favor. So after Ropes's
death, a director is set up to be
basically be the dictatorship of France.
Okay. a fiveman dict dictatorship which
includes Carnau and um also Paul Barah
who is also another patron of Napoleon
as well as a friend of Robespier. Okay.
And at first after Robes Pier's downfall
both Paul Beret and Napoleon are under
investigation because they are friends
of Ropes Pier but because they are
extremely
political politically flexible. I mean
he he is the opposite of Ropes Pier.
ropes pier um was virtuous. He's very
cynical. Okay, he he's he's your perfect
political operator. Okay, he's able to
become one of the leaders of the
directory and he helps promote
Napoleon's career. Napoleon helps them
because at this time there's a mob, a
Paris mob that threatens the directory.
Okay? And what Napoleon does is he fires
cannon at them. Okay? And as a general,
you're not supposed to do that. You're
not supposed to like actually go kill
your own people. But Napoleon, he is
ambitious. He's merciless and he show so
the director owes him a favor and he
asks for a generalship of the Italian
peninsula. Why? Because that's where
Julius Caesar is from. Right. And in the
Italian peninsula um he wins a lot of
battles. Um the the the the record is
mixed. It's not as great as people make
it out to be. Okay. But after the
Italian peninsula, what's interesting is
he then goes to
Egypt. Why? Because the great went to
Egypt and Julius Caesar went to Egypt.
Okay. So even at this particular stage
in his career, he understands how to
create a mythology of himself. Right? I
am the new Julius Caesar. I'm the new
ex. And it works. Okay? Because in
1799, Paul Baro Bar as well as um
Annayas who is now the head of the
government, they get sick of the
republic. The republic, it's corrupt.
It's ineffectual. They want to establish
their own dictatorship. But for them to
establish their their dictatorship, they
need a general to help them out. Okay?
So they need the army on their side and
they go to different individuals. They
go to first general Maro who is right
now considered the best general in uh
France. He's the most respected. If Maro
were to side with them, they would have
no issues with their coup d'eta. But
Maro, he's a staunch Republican. He
refuses. He's like, "No, this goes
against the revolution. This goes
against the legacy of Ros Pier. I refuse
to join in your coup d'eta. So then they
go to McDonald. Okay m at this point
McDonald is like I don't want to do this
but have you talked to Napoleon? Okay.
And so they go talk to Napoleon. Of
course Napoleon wants to do this.
Napoleon's been dreaming about this. He
wants to be the new Caesar who crosses
the Rubicon and ends the Roman Republic.
Okay. And so what happens is Napoleon
launches a coup d'eta in Paris. And at
this point the great fear is the mob of
Paris will rise up against Napoleon. But
they don't because Napoleon has done
such a great job of creating mythology
of himself as a messiah. Right now at
this point after the death of
Rosepierre, people are looking for a
messiah. So Napoleon gets away with it.
And then what he does is he knows that
now that he's dictator he needs to
fulfill people's mythology of of of him
as Messiah. So rather than just sit sit
and enjoy being emperor he decides to go
to Italy again. Okay. So the first thing
he does which is really interesting is
he crosses the Alps. He crossed the
Alps. Why? Because Hannibal crossed the
Alps. Okay. And during in Italy he makes
a lot of really stupid decisions. Okay.
So for example um he had the Austrian
army encircled. Okay. So he had
different forces surrounding the
Austrian army. And what Napoleon was
afraid of is the Austrian army would run
away. But if you're a general in the
Austrian army, you recognize that the
French are divided, right? So I just I
just bulldoze them. Okay. So the
Austrians launch this massive attack
against the French and the French are
now being overwhelmed. But the but the
French have incredible discipline. So
they hold the line but they're still
being overwhelmed because outnumbered.
Okay. Napoleon comes in with his elite
group with his elite soldiers. And the
elite soldiers hold their line but 50%
of them are killed. And so now the
Austrians are just bulldozing the
French. Right. Napoleon is saved
because another French army is able to
come in and save them. Okay. So Napoleon
is taking all these stupid risk uh for
no particular reason and has all to
create a mythology of himself as this
great conqueror because what he
recognizes is I don't have to win this
battle because I control the government.
When I'm when I go back to France, I'll
just tell everyone I won and everyone
will believe me. But what's important is
action. Okay, I need action in order to
create
mythology. All right. So after the Satan
campaign, what he does next is
um create a legend of himself as a new
messiah who will lead the French people
into the promised
land. Okay. Um this is the battle of
Moringo where Napoleon should have been
destroyed but he got lucky
again and in 1804 he makes himself
emperor of France. And this now destroys
the revolution because the Messiah is
not supposed to do this. Messiah is not
supposed to make himself emperor. The
Messiah is supposed to be selfless like
Rose Pierre and lead the people to
victory to free the entire world. You're
not supposed to become emperor. Okay?
Because once you become emperor, you
have worldly needs. He makes now his
brothers emperors as well. He makes his
brother Joseph emperor of Italy as well
as Spain. Okay. He then makes his other
other brother. So this is Joseph. Um he
then makes his other brother Lewis king
of Holland. Okay. So he's basically
divide all of Europe among his family
members. And obviously if you are a
French revolutionary who dedicate your
entire life to promoting uh liberty
around the world, you don't see this as
a good thing.
Right? All right. So the other thing
about um Napoleon is he was extremely
selfish individual. He was narcissistic.
He was he was selfish. And the reason
why we know this is one thing that he
spent a lot of time on is writing
letters to his wife the empress
Josephine. Okay. So let's just leave
let's just read certain sections of
these letters. So he writes to
Josephine. Since I left you, okay, he's
he's in campaign right now in Italy. I
have been constantly depressed. My
happiness is to be a near you. Okay.
Okay, so he's obsessed with Josephine.
Okay, he's he's a general. He's in
charge of tens of thousands of soldiers,
but every day he's thinking about, hey,
is Josephine sleeping with another man?
That's like literally what he's
thinking. He's like, I know Josephine
sleeping with another man, and I'm going
to I'm going to be really angry when I
find out. Okay, that that's what he's
thinking every day. And we know because
I don't love you anymore. On the
contrary, I detest you. You are a vow
mean BC All right. So, this is
this is what he's writing to his wife
who's sleeping with other men while he's
away on campaign. Also, my mistresses do
not in the least engage my feelings.
Power is my mistress. So, this is a
megalomaniac. He's narcissistic. He's
obsessed with obtaining with obtaining
as much power as possible. That's what
drives him. What he recognizes is this.
in order for him to maintain his
mythology, in order for him to maintain
his image as a messiah, he France needs
to be constantly at
war. So even though um Napoleon could at
this time just enjoy being emperor,
instead he's constantly at war with
everyone in order to u maintain his
mythology because the mythology is what
controls the French people. If you don't
have the myth mythology, they won't let
you become emperor anymore. Okay. And so
as a result, France becomes the largest
empire in Europe. Okay. So the blue, the
light blue, it's all part of the French
empire. He's controlled France, but he
controls Spain, Italy,
um parts of Prussia, Germany. Okay?
And the problem with Europe is, as I
mentioned in previous classes, the
geography. It's very hard to control all
of it. So Britain is still impossible to
conquer right now. Britain has the
greatest navy in the world. France has
the greatest land army in the world. But
Great Britain has the greatest navy in
the world. And therefore they can never
be invaded. Okay. Russia is just too big
to be invaded. There's still Austria
around. Um and so now the French army,
it is overextended and people have lost
their revolutionary fever. Okay? They're
not going they don't want to die anymore
for Napoleon. So now the French army,
they're fighting all these battles.
They're losing a lot of men and they and
and these men are being replaced with
just common people who don't really care
about fighting. Okay. So now the French
army is in decline. Um the turning point
of course is in the year 1812 and that's
that's the year when
um Napoleon decides to invade Russia.
And even though um the invasion is a
failure, he's still able to escape. The
problem though is that in Russia, he's
lost his calvary. He know he he no
longer has calvary in battle. Okay? So
that's a huge disadvantage. Also his
soldiers soldiers are fighting a
guerilla warfare in Spain because what's
happened is because of Napoleon's
conquest, nationalism is on the rise.
Before people fought against Napoleon in
order to restore the French monarchy in
order to stop the revolution. Now people
are fighting against Napoleon in order
to secure their national independence
from the French. Okay? In order to
practice religion in order to protect
their national values. And so the
Spanish rise against the French,
Napoleon, but also the Germans as well.
So now Napoleon is way overextended and
he no longer has the military that he
once had um during the revolution. Okay.
All right. So um eventually Napoleon is
defeated. Um this is called the Congress
of Vienna and it will lead to something
called the con of Europe. And this um
piece is being mastered around by a man
named Men Menick. Okay. And Menake
argues for balance of power. Let's just
maintain our borders and let's no longer
fight any more wars because the because
Napoleon his wars killed millions of
people. We are sick and tired of war.
The people are sick and tired of war.
That's why Napoleon was defeated because
people wanted peace. Now um so this
concept of Europe this peace agreement
and we can think of this as actually
like a proto United Nations okay an
organization dedicated to maintaining
balance of power in Europe it works
extremely well the uh Napoleon 1815 at
the battle of water and after that
there's no more wars in Europe okay
until maybe 1856 during the Korean war
okay that's like 40 50 years so it's an
incredibly successful
formula. The problem though is this. If
you don't let people fight wars, what
are they going to do? They're going to
revolt against you. Okay? So, because of
inequality, you have all this massive
tension in society. So, your options are
either you take people to war and kill
off a lot of people or these people will
rise up against you. Okay? And that's
what happened in 1848 during the
revolutions when all of Europe was
engulfed in revolutions. We will study
this later on. Okay? But I I want you to
remember this idea.
1815 the Congress of Vienna Congress of
Europe. Minneck establishes world sorry
establishes
uh peace in Europe. Okay. And they think
this is a great thing. But then you have
the revolutions of 1848 which threaten
and destroy a lot of these
monarchies. And so after that what
happens? Well you now have you have
continue continue continuous wars. Okay.
All right. So that's the so that's what
the um people that's that's what the
elite of Europe discovered because of
the French Revolution. You can either
have your soldiers go to war or they
will revolt against you. That's your
choice. All right. And that's and and so
this will take us into World War I and
the 20th century. Okay. So um the peace
of Europe is one of the major legacies
of the u revolution. But as I mentioned
another major legacy that we must not
um forget is the increase of liberalism
in Europe at this time. Okay. There are
c there are many nations that stop to
adopt that start to adopt French
revolution principles. Okay. But there
are nations who are forced to adopt
French revolution principles like
Prussia because they have no choice if
they're fight. There are other nations
like Austria which will adopt these
principles later on. Okay. So even
though Napoleon will kill the French
Revolution and Napoleon himself will be
defeated by the Europeans, um the French
Revolution marks a radical turning point
in history. Okay, French Revolution
marks the beginning of liberalism,
modernity,
uh humanism, a lot of great things that
now define our modern world. Okay, we
would not be living in the world that we
live in today because sorry, we would
not be living in the world we live in
today without the French Revolution.
Okay, it is probably the most
significant event in uh human history.
All right, so let me conclude now by
talking about these great figures that
have emerged in human history and
compare them. Okay, so as I mentioned at
the beginning of the class without Rose
Pier Napoleon would not have been
possible, right? So this chart shows us
how you compare Rose Pier and Napoleon.
Rose Pier obtained his power through
virtue and dedication. He worked 18
hours a day. He was completely dedicated
to the revolution. He had no girlfriend.
He had no money. He was not being paid
for his work. All he was doing was to
ensure the revolution would succeed. And
because of of his dedication and virtue,
the revolution was was saved and it
succeeded. Okay. So rose pier the French
revolution would not have been possible.
Um he was a prophet of reason. He
believed that everyone had the capacity
to reason. So if you present the our
logical argument, people would
understand it. Okay. And that was both
the source of his virtue, but it was
also the source of his downfall because
he he could not imagine that his friends
would conspire against him because they
wanted to protect their own
self-interest. Okay. And the third thing
about Rose Pierre that's important is he
saved the French Revolution. Now, let's
compare him with Napoleon. Okay. Who's
complete opposite? Napoleon got to where
he was because of political maneuvering.
He was able to identify um political
patrons early in his career and he did
whatever they asked of him and then
together they launched a coup d'eta
against the French Republic and after
keta succeeded he betrayed his political
allies he amassed power for himself
that's how he became emperor okay so
Napoleon he's a great politician we
think of him we think of him as a
general but he's really a politician
um the thing about Napoleon that made
him so successful is his mythmaking
genius. He understood that people are
looking for myths and he knew how to
present himself as a mythic
figure like the Messiah. Okay? And as a
result, he destroyed the French
Republic. Now, what's interesting is
that if you look at human history,
figures like Napoleon appear always at
the end of a republic. Okay? So, the
French, so Napoleon killed the French
Republic, but they have Julius Caesar
who is of the same personality. Okay?
Julius Caesar was able to identify
political patrons very early on and
outmaneuver them as a mass power. Julius
Caesar was focused on creating a myth of
himself as this unbeatable general and
as a result he destroyed the Roman
Republic. Later on we will study Hitler.
Guess what guys? Hitler Hitler follows
the same pattern. All right. Hitler was
able to amass power because he
outmaneuvered his local patrons and
allies. We will we will study this.
Okay. Remember the Nazis came did not
come out of nowhere. The Nazis were a
force incubated by the German army in
order to destroy the communist movement.
Okay? And Hitler took advantage of this.
Hitler got to where he was because he
created a myth of himself as a savior of
the German people. Right? And then he
destroyed the Roman Republic. Okay? Why
is this important? Because it's entirely
possible we are living at another
inflection point in history where the
American Republic may be destroyed.
Trump. Okay. How did Trump get get to
where he is? Poker
maneuvering. Why? Why? Why is he
president? Because he has a mythmaking
genius. Okay, that's really important to
understand about Trump. Everyone's like,
Trump is a terrible business person.
He's lost a lot of money. Trump doesn't
understand terrorists. He doesn't
understand economy. He doesn't care. He
He understands mythology. Okay? He
understands how to capture people's
attention. He knows how to instill an
image of himself as Messiah in people's
minds. That's what he cares about,
right? He doesn't need to succeed. He
needs to he needs to act and then he
needs to present
himself in a way that captures people's
imagination. What does Trump spend all
his time on? He spends all his time
talking to the press. That's his job.
Okay, do you understand? His job is not
to think about economics or military
matters. his job is to talk to the press
and create an image of himself as a
messiah to the American people. Okay. So
the question then is okay well listen if
we see this pattern Napoleon Caesar
Hitler are the same person the results
are the same and Trump is similar to
Napoleon Caesar and Hitler what's going
to happen I don't know okay
right but okay and this is really
important if in fact in the next 10
years and it will probably take 10 years
if Trump actually destroys the American
republic okay then a pattern pattern
emerges in
history. All right? And if this pattern
is consistent, now we're able to control
history because we're able to foresee
and predict
history. Okay? So, that's the idea.
Okay, that's that's it. Any questions?
What was this clear to you guys? All
right, good.
about
Rose Pier Rose being so ob
okay that's a great question okay why
did Napoleon succeed where Rose Pier
failed okay okay I I so the difference
is this if I'm Rose Pier I believe
everyone's capable of reason right
therefore you have a responsibility to
reason for yourself you understand I
will give you ideas but you must come to
your own conclusions you must act
independently of me. Okay. And
Napoleon's like, "No, no, no. People
don't want to think. People want to
believe. People want to obey. If I
present myself as Messiah and I tell
people, follow me and I will lead you to
paradise. People want to follow me."
Okay? And and and people love this
confidence, right? This charisma, this
confidence of Napoleon. Think of Trump,
right? May maybe you and I think Trump's
an idiot. But if you're a normal person,
you believe that Trump, he is a genius
because he's so confident, right? People
are attracted to confidence. Does that
make sense? People aren't attracted to
logic or reason. They're attracted to
confidence and
charisma. Trump tells everyone, "Follow
me and the world will be fine. We will
make America great
again." And you know, you're like,
"Well, that doesn't make any sense."
doesn't matter. Okay, he's trying to
he's what Trump has done is create a
mythology that has captured people's
imagination and as such people are
willing to die for this. Does that make
sense? That's what made Napoleon such a
great military leader because he had
this confidence and people just have to
follow him. Okay, does that make sense?
Okay, great question. Any more
questions?
I don't understand how like how Trump is
myth. What's his
Okay, mythmaking. Okay, myth. Mythmaking
is all right. There's reality. Okay, why
is Trump a mythmaking genius? Okay,
there's reality, right? This these are
things that you and I um see every day.
And then there's these myths. These are
ideas that we have about how society
works, okay? About how the world works.
Now al differently speaking Trump is a
failed business person. His father was a
great business person Fred Trump who
built a real estate empire and then
Trump came along and took this empire
over and he almost bankrupted this
empire. Okay. And so Fred Trump was
spending a lot a lot of his time
thinking about how to make money like
how do I make a great business? How do I
hire good people? How do I motivate
them? How do I steal more money from the
government? Okay, so he was focused on
the very specifics of running a
business. Trump is like, no, people
don't want that. People wanted to see a
successful billionaire. Okay, and what's
a successful billionaire? He sleeps with
beautiful woman,
right? I'm going to find beautiful woman
and I'm going to sleep with them. And
the press is reported and then people
were like, "Oh my god, this guy
is a god." because all these beautiful
woman want to sleep with him. Therefore,
I should give him my money to spend to
invest because he's a genius.
Okay. What what people want is mythology
of
success. That doesn't make sense. So,
what made Trump actually really famous
is is a show called The Apprentice. The
Apprentice, it's a TV show. It's made up
and and and the show presents Trump as
this extremely wise and forward-looking
business person. And he's the opposite
in reality. Okay. But what Trump
understands, this is really important,
is people don't care about reality.
People want to watch a TV show that's
exciting, that's interesting, that's
fun. So if I turn politics into a TV
show and everyone's watching all the
time, they will always want me to be
president. Does that make sense? So they
looks like
Yeah.
Because Yeah. Okay. So is perception
more important than reality? And the
answer is yes. Okay. And the reason why
is reality it is very
um hard. It's very
difficult. All right. People prefer
simple ideas, simple myths that allow
them to better navigate reality. That's
why religion is important. Okay. So what
Trump's doing is he's creating a
religion.
Um he he's he he's creating a religion
about himself right and it's it's it's
really the same idea as Napoleon
Napoleon says this right I saw the way
achieve my dreams I would found a
religion I saw myself as marching into
Asia mounted on elephant a turban on my
head and in my hand a new Quran that I
would have composed to suit my needs mag
is a new religion okay make America
great again don't think of it as a
political movement think of it as a new
religion and I will explain to you why
Trump is so powerful Okay, I think Trump
will be president of the United States
for the next 10 years. It is very hard
to remove him because like once you
remove him, the TV show ends. You
understand? Now you have to go back to
reality. People don't want that. People
want to live in a TV show.
Exactly. Exactly. That's exactly right.
People want to live in a Perfect. Thank
you. People want to live in a dream
because that's what makes life bearable.
Okay. Does that make sense? Yeah.
some
musicians to
be more.
Okay, that's a great uh question. Okay,
so the argument against this is like and
like Trump is a terrible economic leader
and so with this tariff war against
China with this with with all these
policies is is this going to make the
American person more poor. Okay, so less
um money spent the American won't be
able to afford a house. Okay, so this is
really important but um you have to
think about people's psychology. All
right. So, so sorry. Let let me um write
write this down because it's a very
important idea. Okay. You have to
understand people's
psychology. Okay.
People are not thinking are not capable
of thinking in absolute terms. Does that
make sense? Like if I if I I give you a
bottle of wine, okay? This bottle of
wine. Okay? I and I give you another
bottle of wine and I ask you to tell me
which which is better. You're not able
to do it. Okay. But I told you this one
is $50. This one is $10. You know this
this has to be better. Do you
understand? So people psychology is very
interesting. But they people cannot
think in objectively. Okay. People can
only compare and contrast.
So let's just say okay trade
war the
American
consumer is losing ping ping power right
so the person is getting more poor but
if China is getting more poor in this
time right so US goes
down but China goes down even
more people are
happy. Do you understand? Okay. I I I I
I I know this is terrible, but that's
this is true. I don't have to make you
rich. I I just make some I just have to
make everyone else poor and then you're
happy, right? Make America great again.
Make
America great again. Do you understand?
Being great, it's just a perception. I'm
better than everyone else and then I'm
great. I don't have to be I don't have
to be wealthy. I just have to be better
off than everyone else. So the entire
world is poorer. America is happier.
Does that make sense?
Okay. So that's that that's the logic
here. Trump doesn't want to make America
wealthy again. He just he needs to make
make
America a myth
again. You understand? He wants to
create the myth of a great America
because the rest of the world is either
at war or it's bankrupt or people feel
hopeless. Okay, do you understand? And
honestly,
um he's right. Okay, he's absolutely
correct in this
matter. All right, and that explains why
he's doing what he's doing. Okay, does
that make sense? Okay, great. Any more
questions?
All right. Good. Okay. So, uh we're
taking a break. Um and then we come back
from the break. We start the British
Empire.